THREW HIM IN JAIL.
THEN THEY HID EVIDENCE FROM THE
DEFENSE.
BUT APPALLING, APPALLING EXAMPLE
OF PROSECUTORIAL MISCONDUCT.
WE ASKED RITTENHOUSE ABOUT THAT
DURING OUR CONVERSATION LAST
NIGHT.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID.
>> Tucker: WHAT DID YOU THINK OF
THE PROSECUTION?
>> IN MY BELIEF, THE
PROSECUTORIAL MISCONDUCT IN THIS
CASE IS RIDICULOUS.
THEY KNEW I WAS INNOCENT BUT
THEY STILL DECIDED TO BRING
THESE CHARGES TO MAKE THEIR
NAME, TO HAVE A NAME.
THEY WANTED MY HEAD ON THEIR
SHELF.
THERE IS THIS FBI
SURVEILLANCE -- MAY I REMIND YOU
IT'S ILLEGAL TO SURVEY A
CITIZEN.
BUT THE FBI STILL HAD A PLANE UP
AND TRIED TO TWIST TO TO TO SAY
I WAS CHASING DOWN
MR. ROSENBAUM.
NEVER HAPPENED.
AND THE FUNNY THING IS, WE WERE
NOT PROVIDED THAT DRONE FOOTAGE
UNTIL OCTOBER, AND THEY HAD IT
WAY BEFORE AN PHISH GAVE IT TO
THEM AND THEY COMPRESSED THAT
FBI DRONE VIDEO AND GAVE IT TO
US.
THEY GAVE US A COMPRESSED
VERSION OF THAT FILE.
SO THEY HAD A 4 K DRONE THAT
SHOWED THE SHOOTING OF
MR. ROSENBAUM.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHAT HAND BREAK
IS?
>> NO ASSISTANT DISTRICT
ATTORNEY CROSS HAD A SOFTWARE
INSTALLED ON HIS COMPUTER CALLED
HAND BREAK.
AND THIS IS JUST SPECULATION.
BUT PUT 2 AND 2 TOGETHER WE GET
A DECOMPRESSED I THINK IT'S 3
MEGA BITES FILE OF THE DRONE
VIDEO WHEN THEY HAVE AN 11 MEGA
BY THE AND HE HAS HAND BREAK
INSTALLED ON HIS COMPUTER.
IN A NORMAL TRIAL GROUNDS FOR
MISTRIAL THERE.
>> EXACTLY.
>> YOU HAVE TO BE PROVIDED THE
SAME EVIDENCE THE PROSECUTION IS
PROVIDED BY DEFINITION.
ANOTHER DISGRACE IN THIS
GOVERNMENT WITH THE FBI DRONE
THEY CALLED THE CAMERA OPERATOR
OF THAT DRONE TO TESTIFY.
88 QUESTIONS AND THEN ATTORNEY
MARK RICHARDS, GREAT ATTORNEY,
PHENOMENAL ATTORNEY, ASKED HIS
QUESTIONS.
HE ASKED ABOUT THE TAIL NUMBER,
THE STATE OBJECTED AND THEY SAID
HE HAD A TUOHY LETTER FROM THE
STATE ATTORNEY AND WE WEREN'T
ABLE TO ASK HIM THE TAIL NUMBER
SO WE COULD SUBMIT OUR FOIA
REQUESTS WHICH ARE STILL BEING
APPEALED RIGHT NOW SO WE CAN GET
THE COMPLETE VERSION OF THAT
NIGHT ON THE DRONE VIDEO.
HE WOULDN'T GIVE US THE TAIL
NUMBER.
WE WEREN'T ABLE TO ASK HIM WHAT
THE TAIL NUMBER IS.
>> Tucker: THAT'S SHOCKING.
>> BECAUSE OF THE TUOHY LETTER
THAT WE GOT THE DAY HE TESTIFIED
THAT SUPPOSEDLY DISAPPEARED FROM
ATTORNEY NATALIE WISCO IT
ANOTHER GREAT ATTORNEY EMAIL.
IT MAGICALLY DISAPPEARED FROM
HER EMAIL.
THE STATE SAID THEY EMAILED IT
BUT WE NEVER GOT IT.
>> Tucker: SO DIRTY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK MOTIVATED
BINGER?
>> ASSISTANT DISTRICT ATTORNEY
BINGER IS A CORRUPT PERSON WHO
JUST WANTS TO MAKE A NAME FOR
HIMSELF AND NOT LOOK AT THE
FACTS.
I USED TO BE A FAN OF THE
PROSECUTORS, NOT ANYMORE.
I BELIEVE THERE ARE STILL GOOD
PROSECUTING ATTORNEYS OUT THERE.
HE IS THE PROSECUTING ATTORNEY
THAT WANTS TO MAKE A NAME FOR
HIMSELF AND HE IS SUPPOSED TO
SPEAK THE TRUTH AND NOTHING BUT
THE TRUTH BUT HE DECIDED HE
WANTED TO LIE AND TRY TO PUT ME
IN PRISON FOR THE REST OF MY
LIFE FOR MYSELF.
>> Tucker: THAT MUST BE SHOCKING
FOR YOU NEVER -- THIS IS A CASE
THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
POLITICS BUT POLITICS WERE
BROUGHT INTO IT FOR